Here is an algorithm for error defined.
What elements in an agent's
classification knowledge
may be potentially responsible for
his failure?
Let us look at the problem where we
define the false success elements.
I just said earlier.
Potentially, the agent may deceive
a set of positive experiences, and
a set of negative experiences,
not just one positive or one negative.
First the intersection of all of
the features that are responsible for
all the false successes.
A false success again is, something
that we already fine a success.
What was not a success like the pill,
we identified it as a cup,
it was not a cup.
First take the intersection of
all the features present for
all the false successes.
False-success is an object where
the agent identified as a success, but
in fact was false.
Like the pale.
The agent identified that it was a cup,
but it wasn't.
Then take the union of the features
present for all the true successes.
A true success is something that
the agent classified as a success, and
indeed was a success.
Now remove all the assertions of
the union of the true successes,
from the intersection
of the false successes,
to identify those elements that
are present in the false successes only.
So, to put that differently,
start off by gathering together anything
that's ever present in a false success.
Then, gather together everything that's
true for every single true success.
Remove the things that are true for
every true success, from the things that
are ever true for any false success.
That way we get a list of only
the things that are true for
some false successes.
So we're defining suspicious true
success relationships, except that here,
the operations are in reverse.
>> So similarly,
here we gather together everything
that's ever true about any true success,
and then gather together things that
are true for every single false success.
So every single false example
has these things in common.
Then we remove the things that every
single fault example has in common,
from the things that are true for
any true example.
>> As you can see,
we are taking unions and
intersections of features
characterizing different examples.
The number of examples,
both positive and negative, needed for
this algorithm to work well, depends
on the complexity of the concept.
In general, the more features you
have the description of the object,
more will be the number
of examples we'll need,
to identify the features that
were responsible for our failure.